GAMES.
THAT IS .BERGERON AND
PASTRNAK
BOUCHARD  PICKS THE
TOP CORNER
UP.
>> Andy: WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW DO YOU
CONTAIN EDMONTON?
YOU HAVE TO OWN RYAN.
THE PUCK.
SMITH  AND THE BOMB
OFF OF  MADE WHAT
STANDS TO BE THE PLAY
HOW ARE YOU LIKIULLMARK
BEEN RE PASTRNAK
AND  BERGERON,  ANDAND
TO HAVE TO DEFEND.
IT ALLOWS TIME FOR
BERGERON TO PE AND EDMO
ANSWERED AND 44
SECONDS AND  TOO SOFT.
THE STICK CHECKING. SKA
OF McAVOY AND BACK TO
CENTER.AT IS A WELL
EXECUTED PLAY WHERE
McDAVID COMES BACK HE S!
IT AGAIN.
McDAVID AND CARLO
GIVES IT  HAD
HIS MIND MADE UP AND
WHEN HE PICKED HIS
HEAD UPUP
AROUND  AND
HURT THEM.
AND A NICE PASS RIGHT
DOWN  THE ZONE.PUCK.
REBOUND IN FRONT AND
THE SHOT IS DEFLECTED,
CECI SCORES!
ANOTHER